last time on the ozempic Diaries hey
guys it's JY checking in here it is my
third dose of the 1 milligram today I
didn't see any progress this week and I
worked out every single day except
yesterday I saw a pretty significant
weight loss this week even though I feel
like I ate which was is pretty good now
at the 1 milligram I'm really starting
to see a little bit more of a a drastic
change case in point um as of last week
I'm down 12 lb
hey everyone welcome back to aby's
[Music]
Kitchen today we'll be catching back up
with my friend and business partner
ginger on month four of her OIC journey
and today we'll specifically be
discussing OIC as an obsession or an ed
apologies for my voice my kids gave me
Len J but a quick disclaimer here that
this video does include numbers calories
Extreme Weight Loss and disordered
Eventing discussion also please note
that the individual in this series is
not my client so any suggestions are for
general knowledge and for Education only
everyone's needs will ultimately be
unique and should be discussed oneon-one
with your healthc care provider and also
a reminder that this video is not meant
to recommend weight loss or OIC to
anyone or everyone this is simply meant
to demystify a lot of myths there are
about these medicines and also to help
destigmatize folks who choose to use
them so to catch us up ginger has worked
her way up to her final 2 mgram dose
where she's going to stay until she
reaches her goal or discontinues the
drug now before we chat with ginger
let's take a look at some of her video
diaries o why am I nervous I always get
nervous I am down a total of 21 lb after
three doses which is awesome I'm getting
a little bit obsessive over it not
really obsessive over what I'm doing but
obsessive over what can I do to speed up
the process I just like to see results
right away I've done a few things um to
help myself with that okay so I'm really
glad that Ginger brought this up and
she's been so transparent about her
journey cuz I can see how this can
become a very slippery slope where one
obsession with food can quickly become
another obsession with weight loss and
both of these things are potentially on
the spectrum of disordered eating or an
Ed and I can see how easily this can
happen with something like OIC so an OIC
Journey really like any major health or
Wellness Journey can easily feel like it
becomes your whole world and I can only
relate this with my experience when
doing IVF you know it was like waking up
early every single morning and running
to the clinic at 6:45 for blood work and
ultrasounds taking hundreds of needles
every week waiting with baited breath
for the nurse to call me with my results
for the day I've IVF very quickly became
my whole life and it became a very
lonely life because it was very taboo to
even talk about it but you've invested
so much emotionally physically
financially Etc so you know these
results that Ginger is longing for
ultimately means so much when I was
obsessing over my fertility journey I
did find that having more social time
really helped and I had to make a
concerted effort to do that cuz solo
hobbies are great and work was of course
distracting at times but it still opened
up too much space for me to get in my
head but spending time with others you
know doing things that was really truly
fun or fulfilling was really the best
way to pull me out of that Obsession
it's generally harder to go down the
Reddit rabbit hole on OIC threads
looking for quick weight loss tips when
you are physically in the presence of
others also and I know Ginger is not
going to like the suggestion but I would
probably stop reading Reddit or forums
all together I'm sure sunl you get some
really good tips there but it can really
become information overload and can
potentially fuel obsessive disorder
thought patterns and behaviors what can
I do to Target kind of this lower ab
part that's always been a trigger point
for me case in point if you read
something online about how you can use
OIC to like Target specific areas of
your stomach get out of there
unfortunately we cannot spot reduce fat
everyone has their own genetic fat
distribution predisposition and if you
lose weight you will lose fat
proportionally based on that template it
has curbed some of those obsessive
addictive things like I don't have to
drink alcohol anymore not that I have an
addictive personality but like I don't
find myself craving alcohol you know I
don't self find myself craving sugar
anymore so this is actually really
interesting because my mind
automatically went to this idea of
addiction transfer so addiction transfer
happens where an individual will try to
compensate for the uncomfortable changes
to their habits or routine when giving
up an addiction by basically just
substituting it for another
interestingly we do have research on
addiction transfer in patients after
bariatric surgery where there does seem
to be an increased risk of them taking
on new addictions like alcohol or
smoking after essentially curing their
food addiction and losing weight now I'm
not diagnosing Ginger with anything I
don't think that we could officially
call Ginger's obsession with her OIC
Journey an addiction not officially at
least but it's very possible that
something like this might be going on so
it's like OIC has in a lot of ways
quieted Ginger's obsession with food as
evidenced by the Stark suppression in
food noise that she's talked about a lot
but for folks who have a history of
hyperfixation on any Vice whether that's
drinking or smoking or sugar sex
shopping food Etc quitting that Vice
basically leaves this gaping hole in our
life that we suddenly have to figure out
how to film we're so accustomed to
directing a huge huge part of our mental
energy into obsessing over food let's
say that when that obsession is gone
it's kind of like oh now what what am I
going to fill that with where am I going
to get that dopamine hit from so it's
very possible that she's attempting to
fill this mental space that was once
occupied by food with a hyper fixation
on the weight loss process and you know
this is really tricky you know this is
where it really becomes a risk benefit
analysis because we don't want to trade
one disorder eating tendency or em
disorder for another and if it feels
like we may be falling down this
slippery slope I do think it's worth
seeking out some therapy support so I
don't know if there's like a correlation
between OIC and the rise of anxiety or
or depression or those sort of manic
behaviors uh and the mental health issue
so so I'm not a pharmacist and I'm not a
psychiatrist and I can't speak
specifically to Ginger experience but I
did see that the NPR analyzed the fda's
adverse event reports and found almost
500 reports of patients experiencing
anxiety depression or self unal living
thoughts on gp1 agonists like ozempic
now this is still considered a pretty
small risk considering how many people
are currently on these drugs but it's
also possible that the increase in
anxiety may be related to what we just
discussed it's like you have a lot of
skin in the game when you've committed
to an OIC Journey so I would fully
expect the anticipation of what each
week brings to be somewhat triggering
that said if there is any significant
chance of self unal living from a drug
like this there's a good chance that
they will further investigate this in
the research so I am hoping that we have
more information on some of these
potential health risks soon and if you
are experiencing any of these symptoms
I'm leaving some links to some support
in the comment section below I I'm still
disappointed with myself that I'm not
cooking that I'm not making these like
hunger crushing Combos and I'm getting
feeling a little bit defeated about that
oh Ginger please don't feel defeated
about this you know everybody watching
do not feel defeated if this is your
experience I'm not anosmic I have lots
of interest in food and even I don't
always cook or make everything hcc's
definitely not I think there's only so
much that each of us can prioritize in
our life without completely burning out
career family self-care Health friends
everyone has to kind of determine their
own priorities and then even with in
each category some things kind of have
to give so if your priority on your
health journey is taking your medication
and making it to tennis and pilates
regularly I think that's amazing I think
you're doing great that's huge don't
push yourself to make every meal from
scratch I actually reached out to a chef
in Ottawa she posted about this this
company called wef but he is is a
caterer and he does these gorgeous meal
prep I'll be totally honest I can't get
through a full meal in one sitting so
they've kind of lasted me lunch and
dinner every day we've got some rice
noodles some this is ground pork uh
broccoli greens and um this is a I think
it's a miso sauce sesame seeds and
carrots this one is chicken corn and
zucchini and sweet potato I love this
idea again we can't do everything yes
meal services cost a premium compared to
cooking at home but this needs to be
weighed against the financial value of
your time and more importantly your
mental health for some people taking a
big job off your plate just so that you
don't burn out is worth the investment
okay but we clearly have a lot to talk
with ginger about so I'm going to let
her on in hi Ginger how are you doing
hey Abby I'm great I'm feeling really
good today amazing amazing we' love to
hear it so talk to me about the mental
health piece you know I know you
mentioned one of your clips that this
poent potentially may be causing a
little bit of anxiety you're not sure if
the weight loss is worth your mental
health tell me more yeah I um I been
struggling a little bit with my anxiety
in the last uh month or two and and I
don't know if it's the drug or I don't
know if it's kind of this Obsession that
I'm getting involved in again and like I
do feel and I know this is awful but I
do feel like there are days where I'm
like headed towards like my past eating
disorder behavior and like I feel really
good and I feel then I just want to be
better and I think think that's my issue
so I think that's giving me some some
anxiety and I don't know if anybody else
is going through this I mean there have
been some Reddit threads where I've read
some anxiety issues but I think the
anxiety might be manifesting differently
like for them it's like it's not working
or or things like that like the expense
that comes with not working so I
actually I I had a doctor's appointment
last week so it was an iners physical
and blood work and everything and you
know I I addressed it because I I'm very
very in tune with my body and what I'm
going through and I address the anxiety
and she did a bit of a a deep dive on I
guess I think it's called post marketing
or I'm not sure what what it's called in
the in the health world but and there
were no indications of added anxiety
with the medication so that's what she
showed so it's very possible that maybe
I just need you know it's also been a
stressful time with work you know
obviously 2023 as we know has been you
know when you're relying on and brand
dollars and when you're relying on
certain things in this career it's been
a slower year so there could be like
that anxiety of trying to keep you know
six people employed just like that
little added squa so that uh yeah that's
been a struggle for me in the last
little bit it's not bad it's not
manifesting in a bad way but I just have
felt it it sort of crept up so we're
going to explore so we did white blood
work everything came back completely
normal the only thing that there was a
little little bit of a deficiency on was
vitamin D okay very common and it's not
even deficiency it was just insufficient
so it wasn't even that in that
deficiency grade it was just like kind
of below normal yeah um so okay noted
got to fix that um but that was it that
was it for the blood work so we might
try just increasing my so on a very very
very small dose of proac which just
always has helped me get over that worry
that anxiety that constant hovering and
it's just always been like really
helpful for me so I might just increase
it a little bit and try it out and see
what happens yeah so you know it's
interesting because hearing you talk in
some of your Clips you know my first
thought was yeah you know like anytime
you're investing so much of course it's
going to cause anxiety this becomes like
your whole world but it's also sounding
to me like part of the anxiety is not
just a worry it's like is this making me
have an e disorder to trade one e
disorder for another e disorder I can
imagine imagine that's pretty scary you
know there was a comment from our last
video from Jackie hamton who said I
would recommend seeing an e disorder
therapist during treatment there's got
to be a lot of emotions unfolding at the
time during this process especially in
regards to relationship with food and
Body Image have you ever considered
seeing anyone as part of this journey
would you consider it it's funny you
bring that up and everyone so you're
watching like we haven't pre-chat about
this at all my doctor said the same
thing so this so I'm going to seriously
explore this and my problem with
therapists in the past is that you know
when I was living in Toronto getting to
the therapist therapist time and then
getting back to work it was like always
such a chunk of time to like do it that
it added more stress I know I know
that's like me with meditation I was
like I don't have the time to meditate
but I know I need to meditate so I feel
less relaxed but it's making me stressed
it's like I know I know I know I mean
like I'm so yes and I'm going to do it
virtually so that it's not a whole added
thing yes um at least to start so I am
in the throws of finding a support
therapist to like help me just manage
some of these symptoms and we'll see how
that goes but yeah it's just like just
30 more pounds to go Ginge 30 more
pounds to go and it's like okay but
here's the question Ginger when you get
to that 30 lbs that goal do you feel
that these concerns that you have around
food eating past disorder triggered is
that just going to magically vaporize or
is that now going to become an added
anxiety of like okay now I look good now
I'm skinny and now I need to maintain
this and this is one of my concerns is
with anybody who's taking drugs like
this is that this can open up Old Wounds
right and so we want to make sure that
the mental health piece is strong so
that we're not just falling into some of
these past behaviors and thought
patterns that were destructive I never
even thought about that Abby so yeah
maybe like I feel like there's something
in The Universe telling me that I need
to consult a therapist because you're
the second person to say that in less
than a week so and then obviously we
have th those comments as well which
love the comments because it always just
provides us more to talk about you know
right so yeah never thought about that
worry when I get there but like I've
never been skinny in my life so I'm not
really that
worried right but you know I'm saying
you everyone's idea of their ideal body
is going to be different so for you you
might hit that and be like okay I have
to do everything in my my power to
maintain that and it may become a new
obsession Beyond just taking your shot
it's right and I just don't want you to
get there because the whole point of
this Ginger was that we didn't have to
be so obsessed with food we could quiet
that noise open up our life to so much
more and you don't want to go backwards
of course it's and I will say the part
about the food is gone right now it's
just like and and I I will say like so
I've scheduled so I've been doing like
daily workouts right and my workouts are
almost always at lunchtime and it's been
a really good break in the middle of the
day for me and especially because I'm
working from home like it allows me to
get out and do the things but that's
kind of where I'm like what am I going
to be starting like two workout a day
three workout like that's kind of where
and I've gone down that path before and
and my my struggle has always been
because I didn't nitpick you know I
didn't select and I I was always I would
always bulk up and I was really big into
weightlifting and it's just like not
really what I want to do so so yeah so
we'll see when we get there but
definitely apparently I need to consult
somebody I that yeah I feel like that's
a good takeaway from this episode so far
okay so I was looking at those meal kits
they looked amazing I kind of wish that
we had them here at home for those crazy
weeks that I have but I know that you
mentioned basically often splitting a
meal in half because that's what you
have an appetite for so you'll eat one
meal for lunch and dinner and I'm
curious ious if you have a sense of how
many calories or grams of protein you
might be consuming per day that's a
great question I actually have no idea
because I haven't been writing it down
but I will make a mental note to see
what I can get even from the chef who's
creating those meals to see like what
his because I think he does the the
calorie content in it is supposed to be
what like a full meal would be right I'm
asking this not because I want you to go
and become obsessed with counting
calories or protein or really anything I
don't want you going back to any kind of
my fitness pal days I'm asking because
my concern is when you know you're
having a bowl of multigrain Cheerios for
breakfast and you're splitting one of
these meals into two meals and that's
kind of calling it a day my concern is
that you're just not going to be meeting
your protein needs you know most experts
are suggesting around 8 to 1 gram of
protein per pound of body weight when on
drugs like OIC and that of course is to
help prevent a lot of the muscle mass
loss that is associated with these glp1
Angus so if your appetite is very low at
these meal times I really want you to
think about having protein Rich snacks
between meals so like a protein shake is
going to have between 20 25 grams of
protein right there a half cup of
lactose-free Greek yogurt or C cheese 15
grams right there you have to make all
of these eating episodes that you do
have an appetite for really count in the
protein department so with those
Cheerios throw in the yogurt the cotage
cheese you want to make sure you're
getting you know a good 20 to 30 gram at
each of those meals plus some snacks you
need to focus on the protein to really
help to prevent some of that potential
muscle wasting that we are seeing with
some of these gp1 negatives okay and eat
the protein first if I get full then
fill up on the protein right yes I want
you to build your meals around that
protein because the protein is for you
going to be the most important
macronutrient because one of the risks
of OIC is a lot of muscle loss and I
know you've worked really hard hard to
maintain that so that you can you know
do all this great exercise and your
tennis and your biking all that stuff
like that so I don't want that to go to
waste sounds like your blood work is
going great I definitely would say for a
lot of folks who are on these Journeys
getting regular blood work is really
important because if you are suddenly
cutting your caloric intake in half
because that's all you're hungry for
there's a really high chance of
micronutrient deficiencies but with the
vitamin D for example that's not
necessarily a food thing because we
don't have a lot of food sources of
vitamin D but we live in Canada we don't
get a lot of sun we need to get vitamin
D from somewhere and if it's not coming
from the sun it's got to come from a
supplement so for sure that should be a
priority for you but let's talk about
Oprah for a few minutes this is this is
being big in the in the news right no
and like the media is just taking little
bits and I think kind of throwing
everybody for a loop on what she said
it's hard to understand the the
intention behind what was said so just
so everybody knows basically Oprah had a
little like kind of panel discussion and
her quote was even when I started
hearing about the weight loss drugs at
the same time I was going through knee
surgery and I felt I've got to do this
on my own because if I take the drug
that's the easy way out interestingly
the rest of this interview was kind of
all about the shame that she had gotten
for weight and weight loss and that we
should just be kind of accepting of
whatever body you choose to be in or
whatever way you choose to lose weight
so it was all kind of confused because
one media would run with one angle the
other media would run with the other
angle nobody really know knew what her
intentions were which was also
Complicated by the fact that Oprah is an
investor in Weight Watchers which own
sequins which also prescribes gp1 egist
like ozek so doesn't actually matter
what Oprah said the fact that an
influential person in the media is
portrayed as saying this is the easy way
out there's a great chance that now the
public is going going to see OIC as the
easy way out this is one of the things
we're trying to you know destigmatize
with this series is seeing this as the
easy way out what what are your thoughts
Ginger yeah well first of all I will say
it's not the easy way out right a it's
expensive B you have to give yourself a
needle every week like it's not not
painful I mean the needle's not painful
but like let's be honest it's like a
process and in order for it to really
work you have to do the work it's not
the easy way out because as I think the
interview with Oprah which unfortunately
is behind a pay wall so I can't watch
the whole thing which which is really
disappointing I wish she would open that
up for free because I think it'd be
super beneficial for everyone she had
doctors on the panel and one of the
things that they they tried to do is
really break down the stigma and not not
shame anybody for whatever they're doing
there's a quote from the doctor Dr
Fatima Cody Stanford that said it hurts
to see you ostracise in the way that
you've been to to to Oprah because this
isn't about willpower it's how our
bodies regulate weight each of us is
different each of us is unique not one
is superior to the other because the
studies have now shown that there is a
braing correlation to food and the way
you consume food so that to me was
justification in a sense that's like
that's people who don't have those
hunger cues those feeling full cues like
we need something like this we need the
tool but in order for the tool to really
fully work if you don't want to be
skinny fat you want to be healthy you
still have to do the work you have to
work out you have to put the time in you
have to eat balanced meals right you
know my my take is basically I don't
think it matters if it's easier or
harder I think that's going to be a
subjective experience for everybody but
at the end of the day no one should be
judged for getting the help that they
need you know I like in it kind to the
time that Liz cert shamed me for taking
anti-depressants instead of fixing it
naturally with a carnivore diet as she
had allegedly done that wased up and
everyone in the comments was like no
girl that's not the vibe we don't shame
people for getting whatever mental
health treatment that they need some of
us just need medication to help rewire
our brains right it isn't the easy way
out it's maybe the only effective way
out for us if we want to say as a way
out I'm just saying it's the only
effective path that we have to take so I
see this no different than with like a
weight loss drug right diets have
clearly not served you Ginger they've
made the food noise worse for you and
we're seeing that with a lot of people
this is an alternative path no better no
worse just different and so I think this
is the point of us doing the series here
Ginger is that we want people to not
feel stigmatized for the choices that
they make whatever choice that they do
if they want to you know diet if they
want to take a weight loss drug if they
want to do neither amazing everybody has
body autonomy and and should have body
autonomy to make the choices that
resonate best with them agree and like
what I hope people take away from this
and from you know Oprah's comments that
they weren't being misconstrued or like
misleading headlines is that we want to
destigmatize every aspect of weight loss
like what we're trying to do is
destigmatize people who might need that
extra little help you know but also I
don't think you know I my body's never
going to be perfect nobody's body is
ever going to be perfect and I just hope
that you know these conversations that
we're having that you know where I'm
being very vulnerable about what I'm
going through what I have gone through
help somebody and I know they have the
comments you know they've been really
great so keep them coming yeah I've been
like an overweight fat girl my whole
life which is fine if I were happy in
that body but I wasn't so I want to
really just help break down the barriers
and like whatever you need to do to feel
your best self is what you're going to
be doing and what you need to do for
yourself and we should all be
championing that yep we should all be
championing one another and whatever
choices we choose to make well Ginger
thank you so much for again being so
open and transparent and vulnerable in
this process I definitely look forward
to checking in with you again soon um I
I really hope that the next few weeks go
well and I definitely hope that you get
into see a therapist sooner than later I
know sometimes these things can take
time okay I will try my best love it
Ginger okay I love your enthusiasm and
on that note that's all that I have for
you guys today a big reminder to be kind
to Ginger let's keep this a supportive
safe place here and if you have any
questions for myself or for ginger leave
them below we'll try to get them in an
upcoming episode and I'll see you next
time on aby's kitchen
[Music]
bye